Dear friend, it's true. If there's even the slightest possibility that you'll have to use your gun someday for self-defense, this is going to be the most important letter you've ever read. I'm not kidding. So please do yourself a favor. Go to someplace quiet, close the door, and tell everyone not to disturb you for the next 5 or 10 minutes. Done? Good. I'm only asking that you do this because I want you to carefully absorb and consider what I'm about to share with you. It really could save your life someday.
亲爱的朋友，这是真的。如果未来有哪怕一丝可能你需要用枪来防卫自己，这将是你读过的最重要的信。我不是在开玩笑。所以，帮自己一个忙。找一个安静的地方，关上门，告诉所有人接下来的5到10分钟不要打扰你。好了吗？很好。我之所以提出这个要求，是因为我希望你能仔细吸收并思考我即将分享的内容。它真的可能在某一天救你一命。
Well, this is an open letter from this issue of American Handgunner magazine. It's actually written by Ben Cooley, who's described as somebody with 13 years of experience in counterterrorism, hostage rescue, and SWAT training. It is a four-page single-spaced letter with lots of things underlined and bolded everywhere. It's actually a full-page ad. His thesis basically is that you have to have the fighting mindset. Naturally you have to have a gun, but in addition to a gun, more important than the gun, is what is going on in your head. Let me just read you a little bit here.
这是本期《美国手枪》杂志的一封公开信。它实际上是由本·库利（Ben Cooley）撰写的，他被描述为一位拥有13年反恐、人质营救和特警训练经验的人。这是一封四页纸、单倍行距的信，到处都是下划线和加粗的文字。这实际上是一整页的广告。他的核心观点基本上是：你必须具备战斗心态。当然，你得有一把枪，但除了枪，比枪更重要的是你脑子里在想什么。让我给你读一小段。
Hollywood will get you killed. Tragically, almost everyone alive today learns their so-called fighting skills from what they see on TV and in the movies. I say "tragically" because everything you see on TV and film is absolutely the opposite of what you should do in a real life armed confrontation. Yes, I know it's almost heresy to say it, but even Dirty Harry would get his head blown off if he tried these stunts in real life.
好莱坞电影会害死你。可悲的是，今天几乎所有活着的人，他们的所谓战斗技巧都是从电视和电影里学来的。我之所以说“可悲”，是因为你在电视和电影中看到的一切，与你在现实武装冲突中应该做的完全相反。是的，我知道说这话简直是异端邪说，但即使是“肮脏的哈利”（Dirty Harry），如果他在现实生活中尝试那些特技，他的脑袋也会被轰掉。
I've been reading gun magazines, and more than anything I've read in any of the issues of any of the gun magazines, this ad completely gets to me, and I've been trying to think about why. And I think the reasons are these. Number one, its central attitude, its central thesis is everything you know is wrong. Number two, it says Hollywood is trouble. Number three, it tells you that gadgets and fancy stuff cannot help you. What will help you, the only thing that can help you, is the right attitude. Number four, it says that all I need to do is buy a video for $97, and a gun, of course, but mainly video, and I'm set.
我一直在读枪支杂志，而这则广告比我读过的任何一期杂志里的任何内容都更能触动我，我一直在思考为什么。我想原因如下。第一，它的中心态度和核心观点是：你所知道的一切都是错的。第二，它说好莱坞是个麻烦。第三，它告诉你，小玩意儿和花哨的装备帮不了你。真正能帮你的，唯一能帮你的，是正确的态度。第四，它说我只需要花97美元买个视频，当然还要买把枪，但主要是视频，我就万事大吉了。
I read this and I have to say I want more. I want this. Which is not an easy thing to achieve with an ad, because the gap between gun owners and people who don't own guns, like myself, that is a vast gap in our country. It's two different cultures. But this ad, I don't know what. It's a thing about it's everything you know is wrong, can-do badassery. I get this ad. This ad bridges the gap.
我读了这些，不得不说我想要更多。我想要这个。这对于一个广告来说不容易做到，因为枪支拥有者和像我这样不拥有枪支的人之间，在我国存在巨大的隔阂。这是两种不同的文化。但这个广告，我说不上来。它那股“你所知道的一切都是错的”以及“能干的硬汉”劲头，我理解了这个广告。这个广告弥合了鸿沟。
And that is also the mission of today's radio program. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, we try to bridge the gap between Americans who love their guns and Americans who hate them.
这也是今天广播节目的使命。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天在节目中，我们试图弥合热爱枪支的美国人和痛恨枪支的美国人之间的鸿沟。
Act One of our program, the NRA meets NEA. Our own Sarah Vowell goes out shooting with her dad and a gun that weighs 110 pounds.
节目第一幕，NRA（全美步枪协会）遇上NEA（美国教育协会）。我们的萨拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）带着她父亲和一把重达110磅的枪去射击。
Act Two, Fists and Guns. A gun control advocate, Geoffrey Canada, explains the pleasure and power of carrying a gun.
第二幕，拳头与枪。枪支管制倡导者杰弗里·卡纳达（Geoffrey Canada）解释了携带枪支带来的快感与权力。
Act Three, Shooter, how somebody goes from victim to perp in one day.
第三幕，射击者，一个人如何从受害者变成施暴者。
Act Four, Potato Potahto, what it's like getting shot at. We hear from two people who drew completely opposite conclusions from the experience.
第四幕，针锋相对，被人用枪指着是什么感觉。我们听听两位从这段经历中得出完全相反结论的人的讲述。
Act Five, Straw Man. We'll talk with a man who has put five dozen illegal guns into the hands of criminals for less money than you made this year. Stay with us.
第五幕，替罪羊。我们将采访一个曾经将五打非法枪支卖给罪犯的人，他赚的钱比你今年赚的还要少。请继续收听。
Act One, NRA versus NEA. Sarah Vowell says that growing up in Oklahoma and Montana, she did not agree with her father about guns. And then one day, back when she was mostly a music critic writing for Spin and all sorts of places like that, she tried to cross the cultural chasm that divides the gun haters from the gun lovers in this country.
第一幕，NRA对决NEA。萨拉·沃威尔说，在俄克拉荷马州和蒙大拿州长大的她，并不认同父亲关于枪支的观点。后来有一天，当她还在为《Spin》杂志等各类媒体撰稿时，她试图跨越这道分裂美国“反枪派”和“拥枪派”的文化深渊。
If you were passing by the house where I grew up during my teenage years, and it happened to be before election day, you wouldn't have even needed to come inside to see that it was a house divided. You could just look at the Democratic campaign poster in the upstairs window and the Republican one in the downstairs window, and see our home for the civil war battleground it was. I'm not saying who was the Democrat and who was the Republican, my father or I, but I will tell you that I am not the one who plastered the family truck with National Rifle Association stickers, that I have never subscribed to Guns & Ammo, and that hunter's orange was never my color. About the only thing my father and I agree on is the Constitution, though I'm partial to the First Amendment while he's always favored the Second.
如果你在我青少年时期成长的房子经过，恰逢选举日之前，你根本不需要进去就能看出这是一个分裂的家庭。你只需要看看楼上窗户里的民主党竞选海报，再看看楼下窗户里的共和党海报，就能看出我们的家是个内战战场。我不说是谁是民主党人、谁是共和党人，是我父亲还是我，但我可以告诉你，不是我在自家的卡车上贴满了全美步枪协会的贴纸，我从来没订阅过《枪支与弹药》，猎人橙色也从来不是我喜欢的颜色。我和我父亲唯一达成共识的大概就是宪法，只不过我偏爱第一修正案，而他总是青睐第二修正案。
I am a gunsmith's daughter. In our house, or as I like to call it, the United States of Firearms, guns were everywhere-- the so-called pretty ones hanging on the wall, Dad's clients' fixer-uppers leaning in the corners, an entire rack right next to the TV. I had to move revolvers out of my way to make room for my bowl of Rice Krispies on the kitchen table.
我是枪匠的女儿。在我们的家里，或者我称之为“枪支合众国”的地方，枪支无处不在——墙上挂着所谓的装饰枪，父亲客户送来修理的枪支斜靠在角落里，电视机旁边就是一整排架子。我得挪开左轮手枪，才能在餐桌上放下我的碗。
Now I even giggle when Dad calls me on election day to cheerfully inform me that he has once again canceled out my vote, but I was not always so mature. There were times when I found the fact that he was a gunsmith horrifying and just weird. All he ever cared about was guns. All I ever cared about was art. And there were years and years when I holed up in my room reading Allen Ginsberg poems, and he hid out in the garage making rifle barrels, and we weren't capable of having a conversation that didn't end up in argument.
现在，每当选举日父亲打电话来愉快地告诉我他又一次抵消了我的选票时，我甚至会咯咯笑，但我过去并没有那么成熟。曾几何时，他是一名枪匠这一事实让我感到惊恐和怪异。他只关心枪支。而我只关心艺术。在那几年里，我躲在房间里读艾伦·金斯伯格（Allen Ginsberg）的诗，他躲在车库里制作枪管，我们之间根本无法进行一场不以争吵告终的对话。
I have only shot a gun once, and once was plenty. My twin sister Amy and I were six years old-- six-- when Dad decided it was high time that we should know how to shoot. Amy remembers the day he handed us the gun for the first time differently. She liked it. She says that she thought it meant that Daddy trusted us, and that he thought of us as big girls.
我只射击过一次枪，一次就够了。我和双胞胎妹妹艾米（Amy）才六岁——六岁——父亲就认为是我们该学射击的时候了。艾米对父亲第一次把枪交到我们手里的那一天的记忆与我不一样。她很喜欢。她说她认为这意味着爸爸信任我们，认为我们是大姑娘了。
But I remember holding the pistol only made me feel small. It was so heavy in my hand. I stretched out my arm and pointed it away and winced. It was a very long time before I had the nerve to pull the trigger, and I was so scared I had to close my eyes. It felt like it just went off by itself, as if I had no say in the matter, as if the gun just had this need. The sound it made was as big as God. It kicked little me back to the ground like a bully, like a foe. It hurt. I don't know if I dropped it or just handed it back over to my dad, but I do remember that I never wanted to touch another one again. And, since I believed in the devil, I did what my mother told me to do every time I felt an evil presence. I whispered under my breath, Satan, I rebuke thee.
但我记得握着那把手枪只让我感到自己很渺小。它在我手里太沉了。我伸直手臂，把它指向远方，畏缩着。过了很久我才有胆量扣动扳机，我害怕得闭上了眼睛。感觉它像是自己走火了一样，仿佛我对此毫无控制权，仿佛这把枪本身就有这种需求。它的声音大如上帝。它像个恶霸、像个敌人一样把我这个小个子踢倒在地。那很痛。我不知道我是把它扔了，还是直接递回给了父亲，但我确实记得我再也不想碰它了。而且，由于我当时相信魔鬼的存在，每当我感到邪恶的存在时，我就会按照母亲教我的那样做。我低声耳语：“撒旦，我谴责你。”
Now it's not like I'm saying I was traumatized. It was more like I was decided-- guns, not for me. Lucky for me, both my parents grew up in exasperating households where children were considered puppets and/or slaves. So my mom and dad were hell-bent on letting my sister and me make our own choices. So if I decided that I didn't want my father's little death sticks to kick me to the ground again, that was fine with him. He'd go hunting with my sister, who started calling herself the loneliest twin in history because of my reluctance to engage in family activities.
我不是说我受到了创伤。更像是我的决定——枪，不适合我。幸运的是，我的父母都在令人恼火的家庭中长大，在那些家庭里，孩子被视为木偶或奴隶。所以我的父母一心想让我和妹妹自己做出选择。所以如果我决定不想再让父亲那些“死亡小棍”把我踢倒在地，他也没意见。他去和妹妹打猎，妹妹因为我不愿参与家庭活动，开始自称是历史上最孤独的双胞胎。
Of course, the fact that I was allowed to voice my opinions did not mean that my father would silence his own. Some things were said during the Reagan administration that cannot be taken back. I won't bore you with the details. Let's just say that I blamed my father for nuclear proliferation and Contra aid, while he believed that if I had my way, all the guns would be confiscated, and it would take the commies about 15 minutes to parachute in and assume control.
当然，被允许表达意见并不意味着我父亲会闭嘴。在里根政府时期，有些话一旦说出口就收不回了。我就不讲细节了。简而言之，我指责父亲支持核扩散和援助尼加拉瓜反政府武装，而他则认为，如果听我的，所有的枪支都会被没收，共产主义者只需要15分钟就能空降并接管国家。
We're older now, my dad and I, and the older I get, the more I'm interested in becoming a better daughter. First on my list, figure out that whole gun thing.
我们都老了，我和父亲，我年纪越大，就越想成为一个更好的女儿。我清单上的第一项，就是搞清楚那所谓的“枪支问题”。
Not long ago, my dad finished his most elaborate tool of death yet, a cannon. He built a 19th century cannon from scratch. It took two years. After tooling a million guns, after inventing and building a rifle barrel boring machine, after setting up a complicated shop filled with lathes and bluing tanks and outmoded blacksmithing tools, the cannon is his most ambitious project ever. I thought that if I was ever going to understand the ballistic bee in his bonnet, this was my chance. It was the biggest gun he ever made, and I could experience it and spend time with it with the added bonus of not having to actually pull a trigger myself.
不久前，父亲完成了他迄今为止最精巧的死亡工具——一门大炮。他从零开始制造了一门19世纪的大炮。花了两年的时间。在修理了数百万支枪，发明并制造了一台枪管镗孔机，设置了一个装满车床、发蓝槽和过时铁匠工具的复杂车间之后，这门大炮成了他最雄心勃勃的项目。我想，如果我能理解他脑子里的那种“弹道怪念”，这就是我的机会。这是他造过的最大的枪，我可以在不用亲自扣动扳机的情况下，去体验它并与它待在一起。
I called Dad and said that I wanted to come watch him shoot off the cannon. He was immediately suspicious. He seemed nervous when I told him I wanted to record it, but I had never taken an interest in his work before, and he would take what he could get.
我给爸爸打电话，说我想去看他放炮。他立刻产生了怀疑。当我告诉他我想录音时，他显得很紧张，但我以前从没对他的工作表现出兴趣，他只好有啥要啥了。
I flew home to Montana. He loaded it into the back of his truck, and we drove up into the Bridger Mountains.
我飞回了蒙大拿州的家。他把大炮装进卡车的后斗，我们开车驶向布里杰山脉（Bridger Mountains）。
And the National Forest Service doesn't mind you setting off fiery balls of metal onto their property?
美国森林管理局不介意你在他们的土地上发射火球吗？
You cannot shoot fireworks, but this is considered a firearm.
你不能放烟花，但这种被视为火器。
So that's OK?
所以那是可以的？
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]
I should mention that it is a small cannon. It's as long as a baseball bat and as wide as a coffee can, so it's heavy. 110 pounds. We get to the mountain. My dad takes his gunpowder and other toys out of this adorable wooden box on which he has stenciled Pat G. Vowell Cannonworks. He plunges his homemade bullets into the barrel, points it at an embankment just to be safe, and lights the fuse.
我应该提一下，那是一门小炮。它有棒球棒那么长，咖啡罐那么宽，所以很重。110磅。我们到了山上。爸爸从那个可爱的木箱里拿出他的火药和其他玩具，箱子上他用模板印着“帕特·G·沃威尔大炮工厂”（Pat G. Vowell Cannonworks）。他把自制的炮弹装进炮管，为了安全起见把它指向堤岸，然后点燃了引线。
The fuse is lit. This is like a cartoon.
引线点燃了。这太像卡通片了。
[CANNON FIRES]
[大炮轰鸣]
Oh my god. Oh, there's smoke everywhere. It's like the Fourth of July. [SINGS] Oh beautiful, for spacious skies--
天哪。哦，到处都是烟。就像独立日一样。[唱] 哦，美丽，为了辽阔的天空——
I've given this a lot of thought, how to convey the giddiness I felt as the cannon shot off, and I wish there were a more articulate way to say this, but I'm telling you, there isn't. It's just really, really cool. My dad thought so too. It's also loud, louder than I can possibly convey over the radio. No, let me amend that. If you want to understand how loud it was, in a moment, not yet, but when I say, turn the volume on your radio all the way up. Ready? Now.
我仔细想过怎么传达大炮发射时那种眩晕感，我希望有一种更贴切的说法，但我告诉你，没有。这真的，真的很酷。我爸爸也这么想。它声音也很大，大到我无法通过广播完全表现出来。不，让我修正一下。如果你想感受它有多响，一会儿，还没到时间，等我说的时候，把你的收音机音量开到最大。准备好了吗？现在。
[CANNON FIRES]
[大炮轰鸣]
God.
天哪。
It was so loud and so painful, I had to touch my head to make sure my skull hadn't cracked open. Here's something my dad and I share. We're both a little hard of hearing. Me from Aerosmith, him from gunsmith. Hey, turn it up again.
声音太大，太刺痛了，我不得不摸摸头，确保我的头骨没裂开。这就是我和父亲的共同点。我们都有点听力受损。我是因为史密斯飞船乐队，他是因为枪匠工作。嘿，再开大点声。
[CANNON FIRES]
[大炮轰鸣]
Man, good shot Dad.
伙计，好一发炮弹，爸爸。
Just as I was wondering what was coming over me, two hikers walked by. We forced them to politely laugh at our jokes for a while, and Dad set the cannon off again so they could see how it works.
正当我纳闷自己是怎么回事时，两名徒步旅行者走了过来。我们礼貌地强迫他们笑话了一会儿，父亲又放了一次炮，让他们看看这是怎么运作的。
So you work for the radio, and that's your dad?
所以你在电台工作，那是你爸爸？
Yeah.
是的。
That's neat.
真酷。
Then this odd thing happens. When one of the hikers says, that's quite the machine you got there, he isn't talking about the cannon. He's talking about my tape recorder and my long radio microphone. I stare back at him, then I look over at my father's cannon, and down at my microphone, and I think, oh my god, my dad and I are the same person. We're both smart-alecky loners with goofy projects and weird equipment. And since this whole target practice outing was my idea, I was no longer his adversary. I was his accomplice. And what's worse, I was liking it.
接着发生了件怪事。当其中一个徒步旅行者说“你们这玩意儿真厉害”时，他说的不是大炮。他指的是我的录音机和长长的无线电麦克风。我盯着他看，然后看向父亲的大炮，再看看自己的麦克风，我想，天哪，我和我爸爸根本就是同一个人。我们都是那种古怪的独行侠，有着滑稽的项目和奇怪的装备。而且既然这次打靶出游是我的主意，我不再是他的对手。我成了他的同谋。更糟糕的是，我居然乐在其中。
I haven't changed my mind about guns. I can get behind the cannon because it is a completely ceremonial object. It's unwieldy and impractical just like everything else I care about in the world. Try to rob a convenience store with this 110-pound Saturday night special, you'll still be dragging it in the door Sunday afternoon.
我并没有改变对枪支的看法。我可以接受这门大炮，因为它是一个纯粹的仪式性物体。它笨重且不实用，就像我在这世界上关心的其他一切东西一样。尝试用这种110磅重的“周末特供”去抢劫便利店，周日下午你还在门口拖着它呢。
[CANNON FIRES]
[大炮轰鸣]
I love noise. I make my living writing about it, and I'm always waiting for that moment in a song when something just flies out of it and explodes in the air. My dad is a one-man garage band, the kind of rock-and-roller who slaves away at his art for no other reason than to make his own sound. My dad's an artist, a pretty driven idiosyncratic one too, and he's got his last Gesamtkunstwerk all planned out. It's a performance piece. We're all in it, my mom, the loneliest twin in history, and me.
我热爱噪音。我靠写关于它的文章为生，我总是期待着歌曲中某样东西飞出来并在空中爆炸的那一刻。我父亲就是个“车库乐队”一人的摇滚乐手，那种废寝忘食钻研艺术，只为制造出属于自己声音的家伙。我爸爸是个艺术家，一个非常有主见且古怪的艺术家，他已经规划好了他最后的“艺术总汇”。这是一场行为艺术。我们都在其中：我妈妈、那个历史上最孤独的双胞胎，还有我。
Here's how it goes. When my father dies, take a wild guess what he wants done with his ashes. Here's a hint. It requires a cannon.
它是这样的。当我父亲去世时，猜猜他想怎么处理他的骨灰。提示一下：需要用到那门大炮。
You guys are going to love this. You get to drag this thing up on top of the Gravellies on opening day of hunting season, and looking off at Sphinx Mountain, you get to put me in little paper bags, and I can take my last hunting trip on opening morning.
你们一定会喜欢这个。在狩猎季的第一天，你们要把这玩意儿拖到格拉维利山脉（Gravellies）顶上，看向斯芬克斯山（Sphinx Mountain），把我装进小纸袋里，我就可以在开猎的早晨进行最后一次狩猎旅行了。
I'll do it too. I don't know about my mom and my sister, but I'll do it. I'll have my father's body burned into ashes. I'll pack this ash into paper bags. The morbid joker has already made the molds. I'll go to the mountains with my mother and my sister, bringing the cannon as he asks. I will plunge his remains into the barrel and point it into a hill so he doesn't take anyone with him. I will light the fuse, but I will not cover my ears, because when I blow what used to be my dad into the earth, I want it to hurt.
我会照做的。我不知道我妈和妹妹怎么想，但我会做。我会把我父亲的尸体火化成灰。我会把骨灰装进纸袋里。这个病态的家伙已经做好了模具。我会和妈妈、妹妹一起去山上，带着他要求的这门大炮。我会把他的遗骸塞进炮管，把它指向山坡，这样他就不会带走任何人。我会点燃引线，但我不会捂住耳朵，因为当我把他曾经是父亲的骨灰轰入大地时，我想要感受那种痛苦。
[MUSIC - "FATHER DEATH BLUES" BY ALLEN GINSBERG]
[音乐 - 艾伦·金斯伯格的《父亲死亡蓝调》]
Act Two, Fists and Guns. Drive-by shootings and tragic assaults where one teenager shoots another for a jacket or a pair of Nikes are such old news that we forget how we got to this point. Geoffrey Canada grew up in a tough neighborhood in the South Bronx before guns were commonplace in teenage culture there. He's also been a gun owner himself. We wanted to talk to him about that, but first, a few words about the days before guns.
第二幕，拳头与枪。车内枪击事件和那些为了外套或一双耐克鞋而射杀他人的悲惨袭击，已经是陈年旧事，以至于我们忘了是怎么走到这一步的。杰弗里·卡纳达在南布朗克斯的一个贫困社区长大，那是在枪支在当地青少年文化中泛滥之前。他自己也曾是一名枪支拥有者。我们想和他谈谈这个，但首先，先谈谈没有枪的日子。
I'll tell you, it was an absolute shock for me and my brothers when we moved from a relatively quiet area of the South Bronx, to what to us looked like a children's paradise, with children playing in the streets and games. And we moved on the third floor on the front of the building.
我告诉你，我和兄弟们从南布朗克斯一个相对安静的区域搬到一个在我们看来简直是“儿童天堂”的地方时，我们受到的冲击是巨大的，孩子们在街上玩耍，玩各种游戏。我们搬进了那栋楼的三楼前房。
And I remember my brothers and I, we were waving at the little boys and girls from our window, waiting to go downstairs and make some friends. And one of the boys, they looked up, and he pointed his finger at me, took his fist, balled it into a fist, and rubbed it in his eye, and pointed back at me. And I remember looking at my brothers and saying, you know, I think that boy wants to beat us up. And we were stunned. We were like, for what? Why would they want to fight us?
我还记得我和兄弟们在窗边向那些小男孩女孩挥手，等着下楼去交朋友。其中一个男孩抬头看了看，他用手指指着我，把拳头攥紧，揉了揉眼睛，又指回我。我记得看着我的兄弟们说，你知道吗，我觉得那男孩想揍我们。我们惊呆了。我们心想，为了什么？他们为什么要打我们？
And we went to our mother, and we told her, Ma, I think the boys want to beat us up downstairs. And you know how mothers are. She was like, oh, don't be foolish. You don't even know those boys. Why would they want to beat you up? Just go down there and play. And we realized we were literally on our own with this. And it was from that initial introduction, each one of us had to go downstairs, have a fight, before we were accepted on the block.
我们去找妈妈，告诉她：“妈，我觉得楼下那帮男孩想揍我们。”你知道母亲们是怎么样的。她说：“噢，别傻了。你们连那些男孩都不认识。他们为什么要揍你们？下去玩吧。”我们意识到，面对这种局面，我们真的是孤立无援。正是从那次最初的接触开始，我们每个人都必须下楼打一架，才能被这个街区接纳。
And when I look back on it, it was like you had to see where you fit in into a hierarchy in terms of being able to fight. And once that was established, you were pretty much OK on the block.
当我回首往事时，感觉就像是你必须在斗殴能力的等级制度中找到自己的位置。一旦确定了这一点，你在街区里就基本平安无事了。
One of the things that you write about is that you say that the older boys on the block when you grew up would set the younger boys fighting.
你写到的其中一点是，当你长大时，街区里的大男孩会怂恿小男孩打架。
That's correct. And you know, it seemed awfully cruel to me before I knew sort of what I call the codes of violence that existed at that time. That we would just be sitting around, and the older boys would just really set us up to fight one another. They would just simply start, Rodney, can you beat Geoff? And Rodney would say, I don't know. And he'd say, well you scared of him? And he says, I'm not scared of him. They say, well Geoff, you scared of him? He's like, I'm not. And you were just trapped, and I would be sitting there thinking, why are they doing this? Why me and Rodney? We were just friends, and the next thing you know we'd be having a fistfight.
没错。在我明白那个年代所谓的“暴力准则”之前，这对我来说显得非常残忍。我们只是待在那儿，大男孩们就会挑唆我们互相斗殴。他们会开始说：“罗德尼，你能打赢杰夫吗？”罗德尼会说：“我不知道。”他们又说：“怎么，你怕他？”他说：“我不怕。”他们问：“杰夫，你怕他吗？”我回答：“不怕。”你就这样被困住了。我坐着想，他们为什么要这么做？为什么是我和罗德尼？我们本来只是朋友，可转眼间我们就在拳脚相向。
Later I found out that the older boys really felt it was their responsibility to teach us how to fight, because if we didn't learn it on Union Avenue, which was the block I grew up on in the South Bronx, then the other kids from Home Street, and Prospect Avenue, 157th Street, they would take advantage of us. But this was really largely fistfighting between kids that had rules around them.
后来我发现，大男孩们真的觉得教我们怎么打架是他们的责任，因为如果我们不在尤宁大道（我成长的南布朗克斯街区）学好，那么家街（Home Street）、展望大道、157街的其他孩子就会欺负我们。但这在很大程度上确实是孩子们之间遵循规则的拳斗。
In my neighborhood there was no wrestling allowed in a fight, and the kids would break it up if you started to wrestle. They'd be like, no, no, that's not fair. No. I have no idea. In another place, it was totally all right. But we really believed in these rules. And in the end the worst that would happen was maybe a kid would get a bloody nose, but no real long-lasting damage to you.
在我们街区，打架时不准摔跤，如果你开始摔跤，孩子们会把你拉开。他们会说：“不，不，那不公平。”我不知道，在其他地方可能是完全允许的。但我们确实坚信这些规则。最后，最坏的结果大概也就是谁被打得流鼻血，但不会造成什么真正的长久伤害。
Explain what the other rules were. What were other parts of the code of conduct?
解释一下还有哪些规则。行为准则的其他部分是什么？
When I was growing up, you had to fight somebody your own size. I mean, there was a real thing that people would say you couldn't pick on somebody smaller than you. And people really reinforced this, and they would say, why are you bothering him? He's not your size. You can pick on me. I'm your size. And people really believed that. You couldn't fight girls, and these were pretty well-understood by the other members of our youth community.
在我成长的时候，你必须找和自己体型相当的人打架。人们确实会说你不能欺负比你弱小的人。大家对此非常坚决，会说：“你干嘛骚扰他？他体型不跟你一样。你可以欺负我，我跟你一样大。”人们确实是这么认为的。你不能打女孩，这些规则在我们青年群体中是被普遍理解的。
One of the things about this whole system is that you could have a fight, and you could lose, and you could still maintain face.
关于这个系统的其中一点是，你可以打一架，即使输了，依然可以保住颜面。
Oh, absolutely. There was no real shame in losing a fight if you fought well and courageously, and someone was just more skilled than you. Indeed, once that was established, you could accept the fact that someone could beat you. And people would just ask, can you beat Tommy? And I would be like, no. And it was no big deal. They would just say, OK, Tommy's more skilled. But it didn't mean that under certain conditions I wouldn't fight Tommy.
哦，当然。如果打得好、打得勇敢，而对方只是比你更有技巧，那么输掉并没有什么真正的羞耻感。确实，一旦确认了这一点，你就能接受有人能打败你的事实。人们会问：“你能打赢汤米吗？”我会说：“不能。”这没什么大不了的。他们只会说：“哦，好吧，汤米更有技巧。”但这并不意味着在某些情况下我不会去和汤米打。
And so there were checks on violence.
所以说，暴力是有制衡的。
They really were. And typically there were not what I would consider to be a lot of random fights. Every now and then there'd be some fight between two guys who were trying to work something out, but basically everybody learned where they were in the pecking order, and we established some levels of comfort with one another.
确实有。而且通常不会出现我所认为的“随机暴力”。偶尔会有两个人因为想解决某种矛盾而打架，但基本上每个人都知道自己在等级制度中的位置，我们之间建立了一些舒适度。
Now with more guns on the street, what has happened to that system of checks?
那么，随着街头枪支的增多，那种制衡系统发生了什么？
Well, you know it's really changed dramatically. One of the things that happens when you have a handgun is that you don't have to think about the consequences of your behavior that leads you into a confrontation. And what I mean by that is that we actually had to think when we said something back. If we were walking down the block and somebody said something to us, and they were bigger than us, we had to think, jeez, if say something to this guy, am I really prepared to go fight him? And often the case was no, I don't think so. So I'm going to pretend I didn't hear it. With the handgun, you can really say, I don't care how big somebody is. No one's going to say that to me. And when someone does, you stop, and you say, who are you talking to? And you're prepared to take it to the next level.
你知道，它已经发生了巨大的变化。当你拥有一把手枪时，会发生的一件事是：你不再需要去考虑会导致冲突的行为后果。我的意思是，在过去，当我们回嘴时，我们必须动脑子。如果我们走在街上，有人说了什么，如果他们块头比我们大，我们得想：“天哪，如果我回嘴，我真的准备好去和他打一架了吗？”通常答案是不，我想没准备好。所以我假装没听见。有了手枪，你真的可以对自己说：“我才不管他有多大块头。没人能那样对我。”当有人真的挑衅时，你会停下来，问道：“你是在跟谁说话？”并且你已经准备好将矛盾升级。
In your book Fist Stick Knife Gun there comes a point where you talk about when you got a handgun yourself. Let me ask you to read 101 in your book.
在你的书《拳头、棍棒、刀子、枪》（Fist Stick Knife Gun）中，谈到了你自己获得手枪的时候。我请你读一下书中的第101页。
Terrific, I'm going to read Chapter 14, part of it.
太棒了，我要读第14章的一部分。
In 1971, well before the explosion of handguns on the streets of New York City, I bought a handgun. I bought the gun legally in Maine where I was in college. The clerk only wanted to see some proof of residency, and my Bowdoin College ID card was sufficient. The gun was exactly what I needed. It was so small I could slip into my coat pocket or pants pocket.
1971年，在纽约街头手枪泛滥之前，我买了一把手枪。我是在缅因州上大学时合法买的。店员只需要看一些居住证明，而我的鲍登学院学生证就足够了。这把枪正是我所需要的。它很小，我可以把它塞进外套口袋或裤兜里。
I needed the gun because we had moved from Union Avenue to 183rd Street in the Bronx, but I still traveled back to Union Avenue during the holidays when I was home from school. The trip involved walking through some increasingly dangerous territory. New York City was going through one of its gang phases, and several new ones had sprung up in the Bronx.
我需要这把枪，因为我们从尤宁大道搬到了布朗克斯的183街，但我放假回家时仍然会去尤宁大道。这段路程需要穿过一些日益危险的领地。纽约市正在经历其“帮派时期”之一，布朗克斯冒出了好几个新帮派。
One of the gangs liked to hang out right down the block from where we now lived on 183rd Street and Park Avenue. When I first went away to school, I paid no mind to the large group of kids that I used to pass on my way to the store or to the bus stop back to the Bronx. The kids were young, 14 or 15 years old. At 19 I was hardly worried about a bunch of street kids who thought they were tough, but over the course of the next year the kids got bolder and more vicious. On several occasions I watched with alarm as swarms of teenagers pummeled adults who had crossed them in one way or another. Everyone knew they were a force to be reckoned with, and many a man and woman crossed the street or walked around the block to keep from having to walk past them.
其中一个帮派喜欢待在我们现在住的183街和公园大道那条街的下游。我刚上学时，根本没在意路上经过的那群孩子。他们很年轻，14或15岁。我当时19岁，根本不担心这些自以为强硬的街头混混。但接下来的一年里，这群孩子变得越来越大胆、越来越凶残。我有几次惊恐地看着一群青少年殴打那些在某种程度上冒犯了他们的成年人。大家都知道这股势力不容小觑，许多男女宁愿穿过马路或绕路走，也不愿从他们面前经过。
And I crossed the street also, and there were times that I went out of my way to go to another store rather than walk past a rowdy group of boys who seemed to own the block. On more than one occasion I rounded the corner only to come face to face with the gang. I could feel their eyes on me as I looked straight ahead, hoping none of them would pick a fight.
我也穿过马路，甚至为了不去经过那群似乎占领了街区的粗暴少年，我宁愿绕远路去另一家店。不止一次，我转过街角却发现与那个帮派面对面。我能感觉到他们的目光盯着我，我直视前方，希望他们没人会挑起争端。
After having survived growing up in the Bronx, here I was scared to go home and walk down my own block. The solution was simple. I had a gun. I had a gun and an attitude. When I look back on the power the gun had over my personality and my judgment, I am amazed. It didn't happen all at once. The change was subtle. At first I continue to avoid the gang of teenagers. I crossed the street or turned down another block when I saw them.
在布朗克斯长大并活下来后，我竟然害怕回家走在自己住的街区里。解决办法很简单。我有一把枪。我带着枪，心态也变了。回想那把枪对我的个性和判断力所产生的影响，我感到惊讶。它不是一下子发生的。这种变化是潜移默化的。起初，我继续避开那群少年。看到他们时，我就穿过马路或转走另一条街。
But slowly, as I carried the gun with me day after day, my attitude began to change. I begin to think, why should I have to walk an extra block? Why should I feel that I have to cross the street or look down when I pass those kids? By the end of two weeks, I had convinced myself that all of the habits I had cultivated to avoid conflict with the gang were unnecessarily conciliatory.
但随着我日复一日地带着枪，我的心态开始改变。我开始想：“为什么我必须多走一条街？为什么我觉得自己必须穿过马路或者在经过那些孩子时低头看路？”两周后，我已经说服自己，我为避免与帮派冲突而培养的所有习惯都是不必要的卑躬屈膝。
My behavior when I went outside began to change. I stopped going out of my way, or crossing the street, or avoiding eye contact when I passed the gang. In fact, I began to do the opposite. I would choose to go to the grocery store on the side of the street where the gang was gathered. I would walk through them head up, eyes challenging, hand in my coat pocket, finger on the trigger. I was prepared to shoot to kill to defend myself. My rationale was that I was minding my own business, not bothering anyone, but I wasn't going to take any stuff from anyone. If they decided to jump me, well they would get what they deserved.
我出门时的表现开始改变。我不再绕道、穿过马路或在经过时避开目光。事实上，我开始反其道而行之。我故意选择去帮派聚集那一侧的杂货店。我昂首挺胸走过他们中间，目光充满挑战，手插在外套口袋里，手指扣在扳机上。我随时准备开枪杀人以防卫自己。我的理由是：我过我的日子，不招惹任何人，但我绝不会忍受任何人的气势压人。如果他们决定袭击我，好吧，那他们是自找的。
I was lucky that winter break. The time quickly came for me to go back to college and no member of the gang had felt the need to challenge a strange young man with fire in his eyes and his hand always in his coat pocket. I knew if I continued to carry the gun in the Bronx, it would simply be a matter of time before I was forced to use it. My behavior would become more and more reckless each day. I unloaded the gun, wrapped it in a newspaper, took it to the town dump, and threw it away.
那个寒假我运气好。我很快就要回学校了，那个帮派没人觉得有必要挑战一个眼中带着火花、手总是插在外套口袋里的陌生年轻男子。我知道，如果我继续在布朗克斯带着枪，那迟早有一天我会被迫使用它。我的行为只会一天比一天鲁莽。我卸下子弹，用报纸包好，带到城镇垃圾场，把它扔掉了。
Geoffrey Canada reading from his book Fist Stick Knife Gun. Geoffrey Canada says that the kind of fistfights that he grew up with ended in the Bronx in the 1970s. At one point in his book, he's told that one reason for the increase of handguns in the hands of teenagers is because the gun manufacturers, after saturating the market of white males, started to market guns to women and to young people.
以上是杰弗里·卡纳达朗读他的书《拳头、棍棒、刀子、枪》。杰弗里·卡纳达说，那种他成长年代的拳斗，在20世纪70年代的布朗克斯终结了。他在书的某个地方提到，青少年手中手枪增加的一个原因是，枪支制造商在饱和了白人男性市场后，开始向女性和年轻人销售枪支。
It was absolutely-- for me it was a devastating discovery, because I was just really mortified to find out that what I considered to be my young people accidentally figuring out how to find these handguns through some hard looking and digging around in the inner cities was actually a marketing campaign that was aimed directly at them. And they started to change the names of handguns to make them more attractive to kids.
对我来说，这简直是个毁灭性的发现，因为我非常震惊地发现，我原以为是年轻人通过在内城艰苦搜寻和挖掘才偶然找到手枪，实际上竟是一场针对他们的营销活动。他们开始更换手枪的名字，让它们对孩子们更有吸引力。
Names like Viper, you say in the book.
你说书中提到了像“Viper”（毒蛇）这样的名字。
Yes, and they weren't finding these handguns. The handgun manufacturers were finding my kids. And it was not a small campaign. It was funded by millions of dollars.
是的，他们不是在搜寻手枪。是手枪制造商在寻找我的孩子们。而且这不是小规模的活动。它由数百万美元资助。
Can you imagine what you would have thought as a kid if when you were 7 you would know that someday decades later you would be sitting in a studio? You would be writing a book about how much better it was back then?
你能想象如果你7岁的时候，知道几十年后你会坐进录音室，写一本书讲述那个年代是多么美好，你会怎么想吗？
Yes. No, absolutely I could not have imagined doing that. And it's one of the things that really shocked me so much, was that I remember these times as being so tough. But yet I have to agree that this is tougher. It is tougher when you're dealing with the fact of you could die than when you're dealing with the fact that you could get beat up. Both are horrible for children, and I don't want to pretend that it's not damaging to a child emotionally to grow up fearing for their physical safety. It's just more damaging to grow up fearing that you're going to be killed.
是的。不，绝对无法想象。最让我感到震惊的一点是，我记得那时非常艰难。但我也必须承认，现在更艰难了。当你面对“可能会死”的事实时，比面对“可能会挨揍”的事实要艰难得多。两者对孩子来说都很可怕，我不想假装成长在担心人身安全的恐惧中对孩子的情感没有伤害。只是，担心自己会被杀死，伤害更大。
Geoffrey Canada is the author of Fist Stick Knife Gun, A Personal History of Violence in America. He now runs one of the most ambitious programs in the country to help children in neighborhoods like the one he grew up in, the Harlem Children's Zone, which is remaking 100 blocks in central Harlem, and his model the Obama administration is planning to use across the country.
杰弗里·卡纳达是《拳头、棍棒、刀子、枪：美国暴力个人史》的作者。他现在负责全国最雄心勃勃的项目之一，帮助像他成长过程中那样的社区的孩子，这就是“哈莱姆儿童地带”（Harlem Children's Zone），该项目正在改造哈莱姆中心区的100个街区，奥巴马政府计划在全国范围内使用他的这一模式。
Coming up, what it's like getting shot, and what it's like to sell guns to criminals. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，被枪击是什么感觉，向罪犯卖枪是什么感觉。节目稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, guns and the people who love them. We are at Act Three of our program. Round three, Shooter. This next story I think is the quintessential gun story because it is both about the fear of guns and the desire for them, the pleasure people take in them. A Chicago playwright named Bryn Magnus told this story on stage here in Chicago. As a kid growing up in Wisconsin, Bryn Magnus was terrorized by a bully named Dennis Schultz who used to beat him up all the time.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种不同的故事。今天的主题：枪支和热爱枪支的人。我们进入了节目的第三幕。第三回合，射击者。接下来的这个故事，我认为是典型的“枪支故事”，因为它既关乎对枪支的恐惧，也关乎对它们的渴望，以及人们从中获得的快感。一位叫布林·马格努斯（Bryn Magnus）的芝加哥剧作家在芝加哥的舞台上讲述了这个故事。在威斯康星州长大的童年时期，布林·马格努斯一直受到一个叫丹尼斯·舒尔茨（Dennis Schultz）的恶霸的恐吓，总是挨揍。
So he would pound on me really bad, and I would take it year after year, and I would get pretty good at looking wounded so he would stop sooner. But anyway, one day I was with his cousin Kurt Schultz and Marky Welkirk and a couple of other guys at Kurt Schultz's house in his bedroom, and we were smoking pot and listening to Pink Floyd. And the door kicked open, and it was Dennis, and he had his father's Luger pistol.
他总会把我打得很惨，我年复一年地忍受着，我甚至练就了一套看起来很受伤的样子，好让他早点停手。总之，有一天，我和他的堂兄库尔特·舒尔茨（Kurt Schultz）、马基·威尔柯克（Marky Welkirk）还有其他几个家伙在库尔特·舒尔茨的卧室里抽大麻、听平克·弗洛伊德乐队的歌。门被踹开了，是丹尼斯，他拿着他父亲的鲁格手枪。
And he turned and he said, Smokey, Smokey, and then he shot Kurt Schultz in the head. And Kurt flipped over the chair he was sitting in back like that, and we all totally freaked out, and I dove out the window. I just felt glass shattering around me, and I started running. And as I was running down the street, I heard Dennis Schultz scream, get your ass back here, faggot. And I was like oh God, I've got to get away from this guy.
他转过身说：“斯莫基（Smokey），斯莫基”，然后一枪打在库尔特·舒尔茨头上。库尔特向后翻过了他坐的椅子，我们全都吓坏了，我从窗户跳了出去。我只感觉到玻璃在我周围破碎，然后开始跑。跑在街上时，我听到丹尼斯·舒尔茨尖叫：“滚回来，你个死基佬。”我心想，天哪，我得离这个家伙远点。
Anyway, I'm running, and he had come out of the room after me through the window. And I was running down the street, and I heard a shot, and I heard the bullet whistling past me, and I was running as fast as I could. And then I didn't hear the shot that hit me. I just felt this sting in my back, and it kind of looked like this. The shot spun me around, and I landed, and he came running up to me, and he stood over me with the Luger. And he said-- I don't even know what he said actually, because I had by this time soiled my pants, and I was really shaking. And this was no act. I was really frightened.
总之，我正在跑，他穿过窗户从房间里追了出来。我跑在街上，听到一声枪响，子弹从我耳边呼啸而过，我拼命奔跑。然后我没听到击中我的那声枪响。我只感觉到背部一阵刺痛，样子大概就是这样。子弹让我转了一圈，我落地了，他跑过来站在我身边，拿着鲁格枪。他说——我其实都不知道他说了什么，因为那时候我吓得失禁了，浑身发抖。这绝对不是演戏。我是真的被吓坏了。
And he just shot me like five times in the stomach, and I felt each time it hit me. I felt it striking me, and I looked down, and it was like wax. He had taken the bullets out of these bullets and dripped in wax over the gunpowder and put them back in this Luger. And he had done this act of terrorism, which I thought was really exceptionally creative.
他对着我的肚子开了五枪，我感觉到了每一发子弹击中我。我感觉到它们在撞击我，我低下头看，感觉就像蜡一样。他把原本的弹头取出来，把蜡滴进火药里，再塞回这把鲁格枪里。他搞了这场恐怖主义表演，我觉得这真是极其有创意。
Instantly conscripted my next door neighbor, Chris Williams, to steal his father's .38 Police Special from his bedroom that night, and we spent like hours making these bullets. We'd take the lead out of the bullet, and we'd drip a little-- well, first we'd dump a little of the gunpowder out, and then we'd drip a little wax in there, and then we'd put a little ketchup or fake blood in there, and then we'd drip a little more wax on top. And we had it all figured out.
我立即拉拢了隔壁邻居克里斯·威廉姆斯（Chris Williams），让他那天晚上从卧室偷出他父亲的.38口径警用特种手枪，我们花了几个小时制作这些子弹。我们把弹头里的铅取出，滴一点——嗯，首先我们倒掉一点火药，然后滴一点蜡进去，放一点番茄酱或假血，再在上面滴一点蜡。我们把一切都计划好了。
And so then we would go out into the countryside on these country roads in Wisconsin that had these really twisty, turny things. And we would scope it out. We'd watch the cars go by, and make sure that we had the sight lines all right, and then we would enact these great scenes where one of us would have the gun and the other would be running or standing there like, oh no. So the car would come around the corner and hit us with its light, and it would be like this boom, and ah, and fall. The car would screech to a halt, and then we'd get up and run away, and it was really a great time.
于是我们走到威斯康星州的乡间公路上，那些路弯弯曲曲的。我们先踩点，看着车经过，确保视线没问题，然后上演那些精彩场景：一个人拿枪，另一个人奔跑或站在那儿喊“噢，不”。当车转过弯照亮我们时，就像一声轰鸣，啊，然后倒下。汽车刺耳地刹车停住，然后我们站起来跑掉，那真是段美好的时光。
And we did one where we were standing in the road, and I was the one who got shot. And usually what happens is the car stops like 1,000 yards before he gets to you and then waits until nothing's happening, and then slowly goes past. Well this car drove right up, and it was a police car. And these cops get out, and they have strong flashlights, so they can see us laughing in the bushes.
我们还做了一次，我们站在路上，我是那个被枪击的人。通常情况是，汽车在离你1000码远的地方就停下，等什么都没发生后再慢慢经过。好吧，这辆车直接开了过来，那是一辆警车。警察下车，拿着强光手电筒，照出我们在灌木丛里笑。
And they come over to us, and they weren't too afraid, because by that time we were so afraid. They didn't think that we were going to do anything with this gun, but they said, what are you kids doing?
他们走过来，当时并不太担心，因为那时候我们已经怕得要死。他们不认为我们会用这把枪做什么坏事，但他们问：“你们这些孩子在干什么？”
And we told them what we were doing, and he said, oh yeah? Let me see. So I said, OK. So I had Chris set up, and we got all set, and these cops were standing there with their flashlights on us. And Chris shoots me, and I fall to the ground doing my thing. And there's this moment of silence, and the cop goes, yeah, that's pretty good. Do you guys do parties?
我们告诉了他们我们在做什么，他说：“噢，真的吗？给我看看。”我说，好。于是我让克里斯准备，我们一切就绪，那些警察拿着手电筒照着我们。克里斯对我开枪，我倒地表演。现场一片寂静，警察说：“嗯，确实不错。你们接派对演出吗？”
Bryn Magnus recently finished his screenplay, not yet produced, about a morally invisible banker.
布林·马格努斯最近完成了一个电影剧本，目前还未制作，关于一个道德隐形的银行家。
Act Four, Potato Potahto. Now the story of two people nearly killed in gun attacks, two people who drew very different conclusions from their experiences. The first one we're going to hear from is Mike Robbins, a Chicago police officer, who in 1994 was shot 11 times. One bullet that ripped through his abdomen is still lodged an inch from his spine. A quick warning before we begin. Some of this might not be suitable for small children.
第四幕，针锋相对。现在讲述两个在枪击事件中差点丧命的人，他们从各自的经历中得出了截然不同的结论。我们要听到的第一位是麦克·罗宾斯（Mike Robbins），一名芝加哥警察，他在1994年被开了11枪。一颗穿透他腹部的子弹至今仍卡在离脊椎一英寸的地方。开始前先做个简短的警告。其中部分内容可能不适合幼儿。
Robbins was working in the Gang Crimes Unit for the Chicago police. He and his partner answered a call about a gang disturbance. Shots had been heard. They drove down a dark alley. Robbins was driving, and somebody ran up to his side of the car.
罗宾斯当时在芝加哥警局的帮派犯罪科工作。他和搭档接到关于帮派骚乱的报警。有枪声传来。他们开车进入一条黑巷子。罗宾斯开车，有人跑向他那一侧的车窗。
It happened so fast, my partner and I didn't get a chance to respond. My partner had his gun out. I had my gun out. And this individual just stuck the gun in the window and immediately began shooting, and stuck the gun into my chest repeatedly, several times point blank just stuck it into my chest and fired.
事情发生得太快，我和搭档根本没机会反应。搭档拔出了枪。我也拔出了枪。那个家伙直接把枪伸进窗户，立刻开始射击，多次近距离抵在我的胸口连续开枪。
And he's shooting you in the chest. Were you wearing a bulletproof vest?
他对着你的胸口开枪？你穿防弹背心了吗？
Yes, I was wearing a bulletproof vest. And in effect it's like basically someone taking a cannon and putting it in your chest and firing. That's exactly how hard it is. It's like a horse maybe or an elephant kicking you in the chest very hard, very painful.
是的，我穿着防弹背心。这实际上就像有人拿大炮抵着你的胸口开火。感觉就是那么硬。就像一匹马或大象非常用力地踢你的胸口一样，非常痛苦。
Basically in '91 my parents and I had gone to eat at a local restaurant on a bright, sunny day like today. We certainly weren't in a dark alley somewhere where we weren't supposed to be.
基本上在91年，我和父母在阳光明媚的日子像今天一样去当地一家餐厅吃饭。我们肯定不是在什么不该去的黑巷子里。
This is Suzanna Gratia Hupp, a chiropractor in Texas and a gun owner.
这是苏珊娜·格拉蒂亚·哈普（Suzanna Gratia Hupp），德克萨斯州的一名脊椎按摩师，也是一名枪支拥有者。
And a crowded restaurant-- it was payday, and it was the day after Boss' Day, a place that we went all the time. In fact, the manager that day had invited me. We were done eating, and all of a sudden this guy crashes his truck through the window, and we promptly heard gunshots. And when we heard that, your first thought is robbery. It's a crowded place. It's a robbery.
那是一家拥挤的餐厅——那天是发薪日，也是“老板节”的第二天，那是我们常去的地方。事实上，那天经理还邀请了我。我们吃完了，突然那家伙开车撞进窗户，我们立即听到了枪声。听到枪声时，你的第一反应是抢劫。那是一个拥挤的地方。这是一场抢劫。
So we immediately drop down. My father and I put the table up in front of us. But about 45 seconds into it, I'm going to say probably six people were killed at that point. He was not spraying bullets. He was simply walking from one person to the other, aiming, and pulling the trigger.
所以我们立刻趴下。我和父亲把桌子挡在身前。但大约45秒后，我想当时大概已经有六个人遇难了。他不是乱扫射。他只是从一个人走向另一个人，瞄准，扣动扳机。
In my case, the individual, I could never forget his face because his face was closer than yours and mine.
对我来说，那个人的脸我永远忘不掉，因为他的脸比你我之间的距离还要近。
And was he cold and clinical about it, or was he just angry?
他是表现得冷静无情，还是愤怒？
Very much so.
非常明显。
He was clinical?
他很冷酷？
Very cold, very clinical, and just shooting, shooting repeatedly. My partner was shot six times. We screamed and hollered in the car at each other. There was just a lot of screaming and hollering. Some of the things were inaudible. We're going to die. We're going to die. Help me. Tell my mother I love her. I love you. I told him that I love you, and he told me he loved me.
非常冷酷、非常无情，只是不停地开枪、开枪。我的搭档被击中六次。我们在车里尖叫、大喊。很多声音都听不清。我们要死了。我们要死了。帮帮我。告诉我妈我爱她。我爱你。我告诉他我爱你，他也告诉我他爱我。
Actually you would have expected it to be pandemonium, but no, it was very quiet, in fact. And you can ask anybody about that particular day. It was oddly quiet. You'd hear an occasional scream or an occasional moan or an occasional instruction shouted, like get down or something like that.
实际上你本以为那会是混乱不堪的，但没有，事实上非常安静。你可以问那天在场的任何人。气氛静得诡异。你偶尔会听到尖叫声，或者偶尔的呻吟声，或者偶尔听到有人喊出指令，比如“趴下”之类的。
But otherwise it was just completely silent?
但除此之外完全沉默？
Yes.
是的。
I felt it took forever. The shooting was like in slow motion. When I look back at it in retrospect, I see things very slowly now.
我觉得那持续了太久。射击过程就像慢动作一样。回想往事，我现在看事情都很慢。
At this point he was about 15 feet from us. He was about 3/4 of his back turned toward me. I had a place to rest my arm. It was a perfect opportunity.
当时他离我们大约15英尺远。他背对着我，大约3/4的身体转过去了。我有一个可以支撑手臂的地方。那是一个完美的时机。
Perfect shot.
完美的射击机会。
And then I realized that a few months earlier I made the stupidest decision of my life. My gun was 100 yards away in my car, completely useless to me, because I had chosen to obey Texas laws.
然后我意识到，几个月前我做出了这辈子最愚蠢的决定。我的枪在100码外的车里，对我来说完全没用，因为我选择了遵守德克萨斯州的法律。
My partner couldn't get a shot off at a guy on the side because he was-- as he explained to me later on, I was busy bouncing up and down in the car back and forth and up and down, that if he'd have shot, he probably would've shot me.
我的搭档无法对旁边的家伙开枪，因为正如他后来向我解释的那样，当时我正在车里前后左右上下晃动，如果他开枪，很可能会打中我。
Well at that point my father began to raise up and say, I got to do something. I got to do something. He's going to kill everybody in here. And my attention turned to him, and I started grabbing him by the shirt and pulling him down.
就在那时，我父亲开始起身说：“我得做点什么。我得做点什么。他会杀光这里所有人的。”我的注意力转向他，我抓住他的衬衫领子想把他拉下来。
All the strength had been blown out of me, literally. I could no longer struggle or fight with this individual.
所有的力量都被从我身上抽走了，真的是这样。我再也无法挣扎或与那个人抗争了。
But when he saw what he thought was an opportunity, he jumped up and ran at the guy. Well, the guy saw my dad coming. He turned, pulled the trigger, shot my father in the chest.
但当他看到他认为的机会时，他跳起来冲向那个人。那家伙看到我爸爸冲过来，转过身，扣动扳机，打中了我父亲的胸口。
And I felt that this is the way I was going to die, and this is how it feels to die. These things were running through my mind as he was shooting.
我觉得这就是我要死的方式，这就是死亡的感觉。当他射击时，这些念头在我脑海中闪过。
I stood up and I grabbed my mother by the shirt collar, and I said, come on, come on, we've got to run. We've got to get out of here. And my feet grew wings, and I was one of the only people out of the front area there to make it out of the back.
我站起来抓住母亲的衬衫领子说：“快走，快走，我们得跑。我们得离开这里。”我的脚像长了翅膀，我是前区仅有的几个逃出后门的人之一。
How many people were killed that day?
那天有多少人遇难？
About 23 people. And I turned around to say something to my mother, and realized that she had not followed me out.
大约23人。我回过头想对母亲说什么，才发现她没有跟着我出来。
One of the interesting things that happened was that I saw a vision of my mother at the time when we were shot. And my mother had passed in 1982. And if we have time I could tell you, but it doesn't take too long. But at the time when this individual was shooting and shooting and shooting in our car, I somehow mustered enough strength to turn my body to the left. And when I did so, my mother just was in the back of the car, and she just grabbed me and pulled me right to her bosom, and just pulled my head right into her chest. She had no clothes on at all. She just pulled me right to her bare breasts, and just pulled me close.
有趣的一件事是，在我们中枪时，我看到了母亲的幻象。我母亲在1982年去世了。如果有时间我可以告诉你，花不了多长时间。但当时那个人在车里不停地开枪、开枪、又开枪时，我不知怎么鼓起了足够的力气向左转过身。当我转过身时，母亲就在车后座，她抓住我，把我拉进她的怀里，把我的头紧紧贴在她的胸口。她身上什么也没穿。她就那样把我拉向她赤裸的乳房，紧紧拥抱着我。
And at that time there was another loud bang and a big kick in my back. And he had shot me in the left side of my back in the shoulder blade, I found out later on. And then my mother had released me, and at that time the individual who was doing the shooting, he took off running down the alley.
就在那时，又一声巨响，我的背部一阵剧痛。后来我才知道他射中了我的背部左侧肩胛骨。然后母亲放开了我，就在那时，开枪的那个人跑向巷子那边去了。
And I later learned from the cops my mother had crawled over to where my father was, and was cradling him until the gunman got back around to her. And they said he put the gun to her head, she looked up at him and put her head down, and he pulled the trigger.
后来我从警察那里得知，我母亲爬到了父亲所在的地方，一直搂着他，直到那个枪手回到她身边。他们说他把枪抵在她头上，她看着他，又垂下头，他扣动了扳机。
Well, just prior to the trial as we were being prepped by the state attorney's office, they were asking what happened next, and what happened next, and what happened next. And I explained to them, and I explained to them just like I mentioned to you about my mother appearing and pulling me close to her. And they advised me not to do so.
好吧，就在庭审前，当我们在州检察官办公室做准备时，他们问接下来发生了什么，接下来发生了什么。我解释了，就像我刚才提到母亲出现并把我拉向她怀里一样。他们建议我不要这样做。
Not to mention that on the stand.
不要在证人席上提到这一点。
Not to mention that on the stand, because they did not want to prejudice the jury or put anything into their mind, and perhaps them thinking that maybe I was suffering a period of delusion, and if doing so, then maybe I wouldn't recognize this individual who shot me. So at the time when I went on the stand, I told the jury that I had saw my mother. I told them the very same thing. I didn't want to hide it at all.
不要提到这一点，因为他们不想让陪审团产生偏见，不想往他们脑子里灌输什么，也许他们会认为我正处于妄想期，如果是这样，也许我无法认出那个向我开枪的人。所以当我走上证人席时，我告诉陪审团我看到了我的母亲。我把同样的事情告诉了他们。我不想隐瞒任何事。
My reason for saying is that to deny that this happened would be to deny that I saw my mother, to deny that God exists. And I did not want to do that. I don't think that I would be able to live with myself. I would've been better off dead. The individual might as well have just shot me and killed me.
我这么说的原因是：否定这一点发生过，就是否定我看到了母亲，就是否定上帝的存在。我不想那样做。我想我无法面对自己。我当初还不如死了算了。那个人还不如直接把我开枪打死算了。
Mike Robbins came out of the experience a firm advocate for stricter gun control. He got rid of his own guns and began speaking around the country about the issue. Suzanna Gratia Hupp meanwhile became a visible and important spokesperson in the fight to change the gun laws in Texas to allow concealed weapons. Soon after her side won and concealed weapons became legal in Texas, she was elected as a state representative.
麦克·罗宾斯经历后成为了严格枪支管制的一名坚定倡导者。他扔掉了自己的枪，开始在全国各地发表演讲。与此同时，苏珊娜·格拉蒂亚·哈普成为了争取改变德州枪支法以允许携带隐蔽武器的重要发言人。她胜出并使隐蔽武器在德州合法化后不久，就被选为州议员。
What do you make of somebody who goes through something very similar to what you went through and concludes the opposite?
对于一个经历过和你类似的事情，却得出完全相反结论的人，你怎么看？
Well, I don't mean to chuckle. I guess I've just heard this sort of thing so many times, but it does kind of floor me. What I don't understand is that their logic seems to stop at the point that they think the gun is the bad guy. Somebody that you're already talking about is willing to overlook the highest law of the land, which is taking somebody's life. That somebody who is willing to overlook that law will allow a silly little paperwork law, a gun law, to stop them from murdering somebody.
嗯，我不是想笑。我想我听过太多次这种事了，但这确实让我很无语。我无法理解的是，他们的逻辑似乎在“枪是坏人”这一点上就停止了。那个你提到的人，愿意无视土地上最高的法律，也就是剥夺他人的生命。难道那个人愿意无视法律，却会被一个小小的文书法律（枪支法）阻止而不去谋杀他人吗？
If they want to kill somebody, they're not going to really worry about whether or not they can carry a concealed weapon.
如果他们想杀人，他们根本不会担心自己是否携带了隐蔽武器。
That seems insane to me.
这对我来说太疯狂了。
Let me ask you a question. One of the people who we are interviewing for our show is a woman who is now a state representative in Texas. And she had an incident where both her parents were shot, where she was almost shot. And what she concluded from that was that she should be able to carry a gun because she could've actually shot the guy.
我问你一个问题。我们采访的一位嘉宾是现在德州的一名州议员。她曾经历过父母被枪杀、自己也差点被枪杀的事件。她得出的结论是，她应该可以携带枪支，因为她原本真的可以击毙那个家伙。
How can you conclude from one incident that everyone in the total state of Texas should have a gun?
你怎么能从一起事件中得出德州的所有人都应该拥有一把枪的结论？
What would you say to her, though? I mean, she said that if she had had a gun at that time-- like what would you want to say to her?
不过你会对她说什么呢？她说如果当时她有枪……你会想对她说什么？
Well, anyone can say could have, should have, would have. Anyone can say that. I mean, this is America. You're entitled to say whatever it is you want. You have that First Amendment privilege, freedom of speech.
每个人都可以说“如果、应该、会”。每个人都可以说。这就是美国。你有权说任何你想说的话。你有第一修正案的特权，言论自由。
I'm thinking about it. I'm thinking like one of the differences between your experience and hers is that when she and her parents were in this experience where they were shot at, she didn't have her gun. But you and your partner, you two men, you both had guns.
我在思考。我想到你的经历和她经历的一个区别是，当她和父母被枪击时，她没有枪。但你和你的搭档，你们两个男人，都有枪。
We both had guns, and it didn't protect us.
我们都有枪，但没能保护我们。
OK, a gun is not a guarantee. It's not a guarantee. I'm not telling you it's a guarantee. There are going to be times-- and I tell you, one of the things that I dread is something happening to me, my being, God forbid, murdered at some point, and my being found with the gun somewhere in my possession, because I know people who are anti-gun will use that for all it's worth. And that's probably one of my biggest fears. And the fact--
好的，枪不是保证。它不是保证。我不是说它是保证。总会有时候——我告诉你，我最担心的就是发生在我身上，上帝保佑，如果哪天我被谋杀了，而我被发现带着枪，因为我知道那些反枪派会利用这一点大做文章。这可能是我最大的恐惧之一。而且事实是——
Not that you would get murdered, but that you'd get murdered with the gun, and that you'll be used as propaganda?
不是说你会死，而是你会被用枪杀死，然后被当作宣传工具？
Yes. Yes, and I have to say a thousand times over, it's not a guarantee. It simply changes the odds.
是的。是的，我必须重复一千遍，它不是保证。它只是改变了胜算。
[MUSIC - "JANIE'S GOT A GUN" BY AEROSMITH]
[音乐 - 史密斯飞船乐队的《简有把枪》]
Act Five, Straw Man. The guns that are used in crimes are the guns that give guns a bad name. And where do those guns come from? Well, most of us assume that they're stolen, but in fact, according to the Bureau of Alcohol, Tobacco, and Firearms, only 10% of the guns confiscated at crimes are stolen. Where do the rest come from? 60% are purchased legally. Tori Marlan wrote about this when she was a staff writer at the Chicago Reader.
第五幕，替罪羊。那些在犯罪中使用的枪支是让枪支名声变坏的枪支。这些枪从哪里来？好吧，我们大多数人假设它们是被偷的，但事实上，根据美国烟酒枪炮及爆炸物管理局（ATF）的数据，只有10%被查缴的枪支是被盗的。剩下的来自哪里？60%是合法购买的。托里·马兰（Tori Marlan）在担任《芝加哥读者报》特约记者时写过关于此事的文章。
Most of them are acquired by a means called straw purchasing, and that means that they are purchased by someone who is legally able to buy the gun for someone who is legally unable to buy the gun.
它们大多数是通过一种叫“代购”（straw purchasing）的方式获取的，意思是由一个有合法购买枪支资格的人，为另一个没有合法购买资格的人买枪。
So in other words, somebody without a criminal record would go and purchase a gun for somebody who does have a criminal record.
换句话说，一个没有犯罪记录的人去为有犯罪记录的人买枪。
Right.
对。
And so why is this so hard to stop?
为什么这很难阻止？
Because it's nearly impossible to detect. It's hard to stop a straw purchase in action, because the only way ATF knows that somebody's been straw purchasing is if that person's guns start turning up in crimes, and they're traced back to that person.
因为它几乎无法检测。在交易进行时阻止代购是很难的，因为ATF知道某人在代购的唯一方法，就是那个人的枪开始出现在犯罪现场，并追溯到那个人身上。
For an article in the Chicago Reader, Tori Marlan interviewed a straw purchaser who bought guns for guys in his neighborhood between 1988 and 1990, and then he was caught. He served 13 months for dealing firearms without a license. She agreed to re-interview him on tape for This American Life.
在为《芝加哥读者报》撰写文章时，托里·马兰采访了一位代购者，他在1988年至1990年间为邻居里的家伙买枪，后来被抓了。他因无证贩卖枪支服刑13个月。她同意在录音中再次采访他，供《美国生活》使用。
Well, the first time I was like walking down the street, and this guy seemed to know who I was, because I used to be a security officer. So he approached me, and he offered me $200 dollars to buy a gun. And I thought that was quite a bit of money for me to keep in my pocket.
第一次我是走在街上，那家伙好像认识我，因为我曾经当过保安。他接近我，提出给我200美元买把枪。我觉得这对我来说是一笔不小的外快。
Were you working at the time? I mean, did you have a steady income?
你当时在工作吗？你有稳定的收入吗？
No, at the time I wasn't working. So I went on and did that. I told him I wouldn't do it again. I'd just take the $200 and go and buy him a gun.
没有，当时我没工作。所以我就去做了。我告诉他我不会再干了。我就拿那200美元去给他买了枪。
What did you know about him?
你对他了解多少？
Well, I knew for one thing that he dealt drugs. That's about it. I'd never known him to be a violent guy or anything like that, so I figured that it was just something that he was using for his protection. I had known many drug dealers that had had guns and used them just for their protection. They didn't go around hurting people or anything.
我知道的一点是他贩毒。仅此而已。我从来没觉得他是个暴力的人或什么的，所以我认为这只是他用来保护自己的东西。我认识很多贩毒的人，他们有枪只是为了自卫。他们不会去伤害别人。
I thought it might not be a good idea to do, but the same time I was broke. I figured I wasn't going to do it again anyway, so I might as well do it this one time, get the money, and go ahead on about my business.
我想到这可能不是个好主意，但同时我破产了。我心想反正我也不会再干了，所以干脆就这一次，拿了钱，继续忙我的事。
What were the reasons that you thought it might not be such a good idea?
你觉得这不是个好主意的原因是什么？
Well, I forgot that if someone did get shot with the gun, it may well could be traced back to me. But seeing that those guns, they don't usually try to trace them unless it was a murder. And even then, as long as they got the person that did it, they wouldn't much care where the gun came from.
嗯，我忘了如果真的有人被这把枪打死了，它很可能会追溯到我。但鉴于那些枪，除非是谋杀，否则通常不会追溯。即使那样，只要他们抓到了行凶者，他们也不会太在意枪是从哪来的。
So tell me about the day that you went to purchase the gun. Was he with you?
那跟我说说你去买枪的那一天吧。他和你一起吗？
Yes, he was with me. And we went out there and kind of like just bought the gun and came on back. It wasn't no big deal.
是的，他和我一起。我们出去，买了枪就回来了。没什么大不了的。
Did the guy that you were buying the gun for handle the gun? Did he pick out the gun, and did the gun dealer to your knowledge have any suspicion about the sale that he was making?
代购的那个人处理枪了吗？是他挑选的吗？你所知道的枪支经销商对他的销售行为有任何怀疑吗？
Well, he did pick the gun out. But see, the suspicion was thrown off because he did it in such a way that it was like I was buying it. I knew basically what kind he wanted, so we was looking at the guns. And I guess when we saw a couple of them, and he agreed, I agreed, and it was like an agreement that was understood by me and him more so than the dealer. From that point on, he must have had spread the word around, because a couple of guys in the neighborhood started approaching me, and I didn't think that was a good idea.
他确实挑了那把枪。但怀疑被消除了，因为他的表现方式看起来就像是我买的一样。我知道他大概想要哪种，所以我们在看枪。我想当我们看到几把枪时，他点头了，我也点头了，这就成了我和他之间的一种默契，经销商更没注意。从那以后，他肯定到处传开了，因为街区里有几个家伙开始找我，我不觉得这是个好主意。
Did you know the guys who started approaching you?
你认识那些找你的家伙吗？
Yes, I did know them.
是的，我认识他们。
What did you know of them?
你了解他们什么？
That they basically were the same type of guys. They dealt their little drugs here and there, so I didn't really think it was nothing that they was doing that was shooting people and stuff like that. They just probably wanted their protection. They wanted to just have something for protection just like any citizen would, even though they was kind of like the underworld of citizens.
他们基本上是同一类人。他们偶尔卖点毒品，所以我不觉得他们在做什么射杀人之类的事。他们可能只是想要自卫。他们想要像任何公民一样拥有些东西来防身，尽管他们算得上是公民中的“地下世界”。
So how many guns did you eventually supply to these guys?
那你最终为这些人提供了多少枪？
Well, as time went on over a period of two years, I believe it was something like 60. It was in the area of 60 guns.
嗯，随着时间推移，在两年里，我想大概有60支吧。就是在60支枪左右。
And how much money would you make from the purchases?
那你从中赚了多少钱？
Well, as time went on it became lesser than that $200, I would say from $50 to $100. It jumped all the way down. That first guy, when he came along with that deal, it was like something I guess to get me started or something. I don't know. Or something that I would do just because of the money. It was like too much to resist, stuff like that.
随着时间推移，回报变得比200美元少了，我想大概从50到100美元。一下子降下去了。第一个家伙找我做交易时，那是为了让我“入行”。我不知道。那是那种我仅仅为了钱才做的事。这太难抵挡了。
Because I would say first of all the money came first. And the respect that I was given from the neighborhood guys, that that was another thing. It was a different story from back in the old days when-- because I didn't get that much respect.
首先是因为钱摆在第一位。还有邻居那帮家伙给我的尊重，这是另一回事。这和过去不一样，因为以前我没得到那么多尊重。
What do you mean? How did that change for you? In what ways were they showing their respect?
什么意思？这对你有什么改变？他们以什么方式表达尊重？
Well, they were showing it in more obvious ways. There was always guys that never had said anything to me before was now-- oh, my buddy here, shaking my hand, and you want a drink or something? Just stuff like that. So I was getting a lot of recognition. That felt good too. Like I say, sometimes it was for the wrong thing. You get all this good recognition for the wrong thing.
嗯，他们用更显眼的方式表现出来。以前从不跟我说话的家伙现在会说：“噢，我的好兄弟，握个手，来杯酒吗？”之类的。所以我得到了很多认可。那种感觉也很好。就像我说的，有时候这是一种错误的方式。你为了错误的事情得到了认可。
Did you ever wonder what was going to happen to the guns? I mean, did you really believe that the drug dealers wouldn't use them, or would only use them for their own protection? Did you at any time wonder if they were involved in maybe more serious criminal activity, something that would harm people?
你有没有想过这些枪会怎么样？你真的相信贩毒分子不会使用它们，或者只会用于自卫吗？你有没有怀疑过他们可能涉及更严重的犯罪活动，或者伤害他人？
Yes, I did begin to wonder and think that they will probably be harming someone with them, because some of these guys didn't look as nice as they should look, so I figured that even though they was just dealing drugs, they might be more than just drug dealers. And I wanted to get out of that racket for sure, but I couldn't just-- I wanted to tell them that I had lost my gun card, or it got shreded or anything. But I ended up not being a good liar, I guess.
是的，我开始怀疑并认为他们可能会用这些枪去伤害别人，因为有些家伙看起来不像他们应该看起来的那样好人，所以我意识到即使他们只是贩毒，他们可能不仅仅是毒贩。我确实想退出这个勾当，但我无法……我想告诉他们我把买枪卡弄丢了，或者撕毁了。但我看来不擅长撒谎。
Did you actually try?
你真的尝试过吗？
Well no, I didn't. I didn't.
嗯，没有。我没试过。
Did you ever hear about the guns being used in crimes?
你有没有听说过这些枪被用于犯罪？
Yes, I did. A few were used in crimes I heard of. The shootings that I did know about always happened because someone was trying to either stick up one of those dealers, and then ended up getting shot themselves. That's all. It wasn't too much other than that.
听说过。我听说有几把被用于犯罪。我所知道的枪击事件总是因为有人想抢劫其中一个毒贩，结果自己反而被射杀。就是这样。除此之外没别的。
Well, there was once a wild shooting spree that happened, but I think a couple of people did get shot, but no one got killed. I never knew of any murder exactly, although those federal guys did tell me there was a murder on one of them. But it was like out of state or something.
好吧，有一次发生了疯狂的枪击事件，我想有几个人被打伤了，但没人死亡。我不确定有谋杀案，尽管那些联邦人员确实告诉过我其中一把牵涉到谋杀案。但那是在州外发生的。
So were you living off of the income that you were making from buying the guns?
那你当时靠买枪赚的钱生活吗？
Yes, I was living off of that, and probably a little public aid, general assistance.
是的，我靠那个生活，大概还有一点公共援助和救济金。
So how much would you estimate that you made in the two years that you were buying the guns?
那你估计这两年里你靠买枪赚了多少钱？
I never really gave that a good thought, but I know it would have been somewhere in the $4,000 or $5,000 range.
我没仔细想过，但我知道大概在4000到5000美元左右。
So you weren't getting rich off of this.
所以你并没有因此发大财。
No way. It was just something to keep my head above water.
绝不可能。这仅仅是让我维持生计。
This straw purchaser was interviewed by Tori Marlan. Only 14 of his guns, out of over 60, have been recovered by police.
这位代购者由托里·马兰采访。他买的60多支枪中，只有14支被警察收回。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Senior editor for this show, Paul Tough. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Alex Blumberg, Rachel Howard, Laura Baggett, and Brian Reed.
今天的节目由朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）和我本人制作，艾历克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）协助。节目高级编辑保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）。撰稿编辑杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）和萨拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自艾历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、蕾切尔·霍华德（Rachel Howard）、劳拉·巴格特（Laura Baggett）和布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Today's program was first broadcast in 1997. Mike Robbins, the police officer who you heard in Act Four of the show, died a decade after that first broadcast. He died in 2008. He was 57. He volunteered with kids in Chicago and remained a vocal activist for stricter handgun control until his death.
今天的节目首播于1997年。 Act Four中提到的警察麦克·罗宾斯在节目首播十年后去世。他于2008年去世。享年57岁。他曾在芝加哥为孩子们做志愿者，直到去世前一直是一位严厉管制手枪的积极倡导者。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who describes the first time here at public radio this way.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。节目的WBEZ管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他这样描述在公共电台的第一次经历。
The sound it made was as big as God. It kicked little me back to the ground like a bully, like a foe. It hurt.
它的声音大如上帝。它像个恶霸、像个敌人一样把我这个小个子踢倒在地。那很痛。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带给大家更多“美国生活”的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。